joe biden finally holds his press
conference
much much later than any president in
modern history held their
first press conference and in it
he he didn't inspire a lot of confidence
he he obviously said
that he has to run for in 2024 because
if he says that
he's not going to run in 2024 he
instantly becomes a lame
duck so within two months of being in
office
he will be completely ineffective he
won't be able to get
any of his agenda through however when
reporters pressed him on this question
of really 82 years old you're going to
run for president
joe biden seemed to add a little caveat
here
so is that a yes that you are running
for re-election look i
i don't know where you guys come from
man i've never been able to travel i'm a
great respecter of fate i've never been
able to plan four and a half three and a
half years ahead for certain
and if you do if you do run will vice
president harris be on your ticket
i would fully expect that to be the case
she's doing a great job she's a great
partner
she's a great partner and do you believe
you'll be running against former
president trump
oh come on i don't even think about i
don't i have no idea i have no idea if
it'll be a republican party
do you i know you don't have to answer
my question but i mean
you know do you i mean look this is the
way i view things i become a great
respecter of fate in my life
i set a goal of this in front of me to
get things done
for the people i care most about which
are hard-working decent american people
of getting really
having it stuck to them so mr president
are you going to run again
i'm a great respecter of fate does not
does not exactly inspire confidence
that i'm a great respecter of fate oh my
gosh i see the point
that he thinks he's making is that look
anything can happen in this world
and you can count on some people and
then you're going to lose them and
you know i get it he's he's actually i
think referring to
the personal tragedies in his life
deaths of family members
but when you're asked the question hey
you're going to be a little up there in
age are you going to be able to run and
he says i'm a great respecter of fate
i sort of undercuts his previous answer
joe biden he he actually got in trouble
yesterday because he was giving an
answer and he said
you know look when i first got to the
senate 120 years ago
and and people are playing this as
though this was some sort of a gaffe i
don't think it's a gaffe i think he was
actually trying to make a joke
but the reality is maybe it wasn't 120
years ago but he did get to the senate a
long time ago
and so that sort of self-awareness even
if he's being a little self-effacing
about it
does remind you this is a a very old guy
by the standards of presidents
and so sure he can he can say
you bet i'm absolutely gonna i'm gonna
run for seven more terms
because he wants to protect his agenda
but i just don't think people
are really buying it now what is that
radical agenda
part of it is ending the filibuster to
be able to ram
through more more legislation than
otherwise he would because i think he
believes that
time may be limited i'm going to say
something outrageous
i have never been particularly poor at
calculating how to get things done in
the united states senate so the best way
to get something done
if you if it holds near and dear to you
that you
like to be able to anyway
i'm we're we're going to get a lot done
and if we have to if there's complete
lockdown and chaos as a consequence of
the filibuster then
we'll have to go beyond what i'm talking
about
okay um hang on
uh sorry
oh sing me miss kim
oh man i'm
there there are some things when
politicians
flail around and make mistakes and seem
incoherent there are some times
when you can just make a lot of jokes
about it you know there's sometimes when
it's so
pathetic that i actually think it's sort
of wrong to make jokes about it so i'm
not going to i'm actually going to try
to interpret what joe biden
is failing to say here what he's trying
desperately but failing to say
which is he says you know i've never
been i'm one not one who can't get
things
done in the senate i know and so what
i'm saying is and you can't well anyway
and then he second guesses himself and
he
either forgets what he's saying or i
think even more likely doesn't
want to admit what he's saying because
he's he would be kind of giving away the
game here
but what it what he seems to be implying
is
i don't want to get rid of the
filibuster but
i know that i have to threaten to get
rid of the filibuster to convince
certain senators to go along
with my extremely radical legislation
that i have to pass
right now one because i'm a politician
that doesn't have any beliefs so i go
where the party is and the party's far
left
but two because i'm very unlikely to run
a successful campaign
in in a few years so i've got to get it
all done now that's
that is actually what i think is going
on in his head because not that long ago
joe biden was saying
that he was praying praying to god
that that we wouldn't end the filibuster
in the u.s senate
is what really is going on here the
majority doesn't want to hear what
others have to say
even it's the truth senator moynihan my
good friend who i served with for years
said
you're entitled your own opinion but not
your own facts
the nuclear op option abandons america's
sense of fair play
it's the one thing this country stands
for not building a player and feel
inside on the side of those
who control and own the field
i say to my friends the republican side
you may own the field right now
but you won't own it forever
and i pray god when the democrats take
back control we
don't make the kind of naked power grab
you are doing
so i pray to god that we democrats when
we take back the field we don't have the
naked power grab
that you're trying to do by ending the
filibuster the naked power grab
by ending the filibuster that is the
essence of our country it's what america
stands for right
you cannot speak in more glowing terms
about the filibuster
and you cannot more clearly state you
oppose getting rid of it and i suspect
biden actually does
oppose getting rid of it but he's
obviously quite weak
you just have to listen to those two
clips it's not that biden used to be
winston churchill or anything but he has
obviously declined
he's not really in control it would seem
of much of anything and
he recognizes that he doesn't have a
whole lot of time to get his his agenda
through
joe the prayer is in your power you can
muster that prayer
and and you can actually effect the
change you want
or the consistency you want and not end
the filibuster i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the michael knowles show
to check out the full episode hit the
link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]